you know when covet first started I was
in a period of massive pivoting and
reinvention like so many and as a
creative person chaos is my happy place
like I can't be there sustainably the
whole time but in moments of chaos there
is massive creativity and so in I was
embarrassed because I was having fun and
yet around me was
death and destruction and bankruptcy and
and I was very torn like I can't be
enjoying myself I have to be I have to
feel sadness and guilt and one of the
huge things I've learned I've learned as
a human being is we actually can have
simultaneous feelings we can have
feelings at the same time that our
apparent opposite I can be sad and
excited at the same time so that's been
really helpful to me not only at work
but it's been really helpful to me in my
personal life as well just to have all
the feels whenever they happen